today on the matt wall show it is
officially time for blm to be labeled a
domestic
terror group i'll make the case for that
today also five headlines including the
dnc convention which was mostly
horrifically boring as you'd expect
except for one
incredible moment that i'll play for you
and in our daily cancellation i'm going
to cancel everyone on the left
who can't make up their minds about
whether women
are supposed to be respected or not i
know how i feel about that but i can't
figure out how they feel we'll talk
about that
all on the way but first let's discuss
uh lifelock look you need to secure
yourself when you're on the internet
protect yourself
um or or you leave yourself open to the
bad guys and there are a lot of them out
there
i'm afraid to say here's some troubling
news for example for
companies who utilize enterprise vpn
for employees working from home over 900
vpn servers at a large enterprise
security provider were hacked usernames
passwords have been shared on a forum
used by ransomware gangs enterprise vpn
servers are used to give employees
secure access
to corporate networks compromised vpn
servers can allow hackers
access to a company's entire internal
network and that's why
we need to be responsible protect
ourselves that's what this is about it's
not about being paranoid or preparing
yourself for some outlandish thing
that'll never happen no this is about
responding to very real threats
that we all face every day on the
internet you know fact is every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet good thing there's lifelock
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number being for sale in the
dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they're
gonna send you an alert
and uh and then you take care of it from
there no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own
join them now save up to 25 off your
first year go to
lifelock.com waltz that's lifelock
lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
okay over the weekend a blm activist in
portland
told a cheering crowd that the police
officers involved in the george floyd
case
should have been strangled to death by
their umbilical cords as babies
and throughout her deranged rant she
repeatedly intimated that she's ready
and willing to shoot cops
all of her violent fantasies and threats
were met with vocal approval by the
crowd take a listen
your mother's umbilical cord
should have wrapped around your neck and
choked you
just the way you choked george ford you
felt
[Music]
[Applause]
it should not have wrapped around your
neck once it should have wrapped around
your neck
three two times not six times or seven
times
it should have wrapped around your neck
so many times
so when you yell i can not breathe
after that umbilical cord wrapped around
your neck seven times
god dammit she should have spit you out
the back of her um
you think that you a a good person
because you have a gun
my comrades already know i tell them
every thursday
right there in their face i know you got
a gun
but so do i go ahead and shoot me
i'm shooting back
[Music]
am i in my contract you shoot me i'm
gonna shoot you back
now this is even more deranged than the
bl
blm leader in chicago we talked about
last week openly encouraging and
defending looting
and in case you didn't hear that um i'll
just i'll play it again for you listen
to this
i don't care if somebody decides to loot
a gucci
or a macy's or a nike because that makes
sure that that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about them
not only that that's reparations that is
reparations
anything they want to take take it
because these businesses have insurance
they're going to get their money back my
people aren't getting anything
so you see this kind of rhetoric from
blm is very common and lest anyone make
the mistake of
taking those violent words from the blm
leader in portland as empty bluster
it was only hours later that blm and
antifa activists beat a man unconscious
and left him unresponsive on the street
we discussed this yesterday as well but
i'm not quite ready to move on like much
of
like the media certainly is anyway blm
tried to kill a guy
in full view of cameras i think this is
a pretty big deal
uh so we'll play some of that footage as
i continue talking here if you haven't
seen it the lead up to this latest bit
of barbaric violence
has come into fuller focus it appears
that the victim
attempted to drive away from an angry
mob and crashed his vehicle in the
process he was then
quote detained not by cops but by the
rioters
some of whom were sporting jackets that
ironically said
security um they continued to threaten
the man
randomly pummel him until one activist
ran up from behind
kicked him in the in the face and uh and
sent his head crashing into the pavement
while he lay there unconscious and
bleeding they robbed his truck
and continued taunting him police were
nowhere to be seen throughout this
entire incident
nothing that happened in portland that
night was
new and if they succeeded in killing the
victim
and this was attempted murder that
wouldn't be new either and
you know in just the first few weeks of
rioting nearly 20 people were killed
we're now approaching three full months
of violence and anarchy with no signs of
abatement
the rioters have essentially held
portland hostage for weeks
in seattle they've made their way into
the suburbs where they're terrorizing
communities demanding that residents
give up their homes
they caused half a billion dollars in
damage in minneapolis in atlanta they
killed an eight-year-old child
and if we zoom out a little bit farther
um
we see that the death of george floyd
was merely accelerant on a fire that had
already been burning antifa
has engaged in open political terrorism
for years leftist protesters quote
unquote have long since been emboldened
to flout laws with impunity
recall the climate activists last year
feels like a million years ago just last
year
periodically shutting down traffic in
cities across the country
an act that we should always keep in
mind is in fact
illegal despite how it may seem given
that leftists do do it so often and are
never arrested for it
blm specifically has been wreaking havoc
and destruction ever since it gained
national recognition
on the heels of the completely justified
shooting of the violent criminal
michael brown in ferguson missouri blm
riots in st louis baltimore and
elsewhere
caused damage years ago from which those
cities still have not recovered
in dallas in 2016 five police officers
were executed during a blm protest
the point here is that these incidents
are not isolated
they are not spontaneous
they don't even have anything to do with
george floyd this is part of a growing
and coordinated movement
a movement explicitly supported by many
of the democrat mayors and governors of
these cities and states where this is
all happening
and the support goes higher up than that
all the way up to the most prominent
democrats in congress
as we played yesterday on the same
weekend that left-wing activists were
dragging a man
out of his crashed vehicle and beating
him half to death representative ayanna
presley went on msnbc
called for more unrest in the streets
what we're witnessing
is certainly not a protest and even the
word riots
doesn't quite capture it this is a
movement
well funded and supported to destabilize
our society and
overthrow our government it is
insurrection
and the insurrectionists are quite clear
about that if only we listen
and take them seriously fortunately
there's an
act for that president trump
should do what he has repeatedly
threatened to do and
invoke the insurrection act to deal with
violent criminals who are
currently engaged in this coordinated
campaign of terror and destruction
we use the military to establish order
in cities 10
000 miles away protecting citizens that
are not our countrymen in parts of the
world
most of us have never been to if the if
the military can do that over there
they can do it here and to those of us
who came of age in the era of non-stop
interventionist war in the middle east
it seems that first scandal is to
suggest
that the american military can actually
be used to protect american cities
but it can and should
these violent elements will not stop
will not stop
until they are made to stop only
overwhelming force
at this point can accomplish that and
it's time for president trump to do
what needs to be done months ago trump
announced that antifa would be
would be declared a domestic terror
group he tweeted that remember that
what happened with that what came of it
why aren't antifa leaders being rounded
up and prosecuted if you consider them
domestic terrorists which they are
blm should get the exact same label blm
is a domestic terror group
it has been using violence and terror to
get its message across for years
and as you have heard yourself its
leaders openly justify and
advocate for those methods that is
terrorism by any definition of the term
and if somehow a label like domestic
terror group
still sounds harsh to you when applied
to blm
then i would suggest first of all that
you get your head out of whatever hole
it happens to be stuck in at the moment
and second i'd ask you to imagine
what would have been said about the tea
party
uh and how the tea party would have been
treated by obama
if any single one of these violent
incidents from a blm rally had happened
at a tea party rally
i don't even mean all of them i mean
just one of them take one at random
take just the latest imagine a white tea
party activist
kicking a black man until he's
unconscious and then imagine other tea
partiers
robbing him while he lay there bleeding
on the pavement
and assaulted his girlfriend or his wife
while they're at it
you can't imagine this sort of thing
really because it would never
ever happen at a conservative protest
but imagine it anyway
that alone all by itself even without
the history of arson and looting and the
dead cops and the other dead people and
the assaults and the leaders talking
about strangling babies
even without that that one incident
would be enough to get the tea party
forcibly disbanded by the government and
we all know that
yet blm does what it wants no
consequence
and still even many on the right pretend
that it's some kind of legitimate
organization
with a good and useful message well it's
not
and it's time that we start treating it
accordingly
let's go to five headlines
the dnc was last night i said yesterday
that i'd rather stick my face in a
blender than watch it but fortunately my
blender
wasn't working well actually i got the
blender working last night so i was able
to do that
instead blended the old face um you
can't tell the difference though
due to the fact that i'm uh hideous
you know but anyway i uh i didn't watch
the dnc i don't care about it
though there are two clips from the
proceedings that i saw that
maybe are are worth playing and
responding to we'll save the second one
the most important one
for the last on the list on the five
headlines but
first one we'll play this this is uh
michelle obama speaking at the dnc and
here's what she had to say
and here at home as george floyd
brianna taylor and a never-ending list
of
innocent people of color continue to be
murdered stating the simple fact that a
black life
matters is still met with derision
from the nation's highest office
because whenever we look to this white
house for some leadership
or consolation or any semblance of
steadiness
what we get instead is chaos division
and a total and utter lack of empathy
empathy that's something i've been
thinking a lot about lately
now you know i actually agree with her
that the white house hasn't done nearly
enough to address the chaos
as i was just talking about but i'm
quite sure that she would not like
my idea for addressing the chaos i agree
i agree there's too much chaos
more needs to be done but i don't think
that she'd be in favor of sending in the
military for example which is what
should be done
as for the rest of it she says that
black people continue to be murdered
i agree with that also and i agree with
a lot of this she's absolutely right
black people are murdered every day they
are murdered at a
far more than any other group they are
at a much higher risk of being victims
both of murder and other violent crimes
all of that is true but the thing
that michelle obama doesn't mention and
that no other democrat will ever mention
is that the vast
vast overwhelming majority of black
people who are murdered
are murdered by members of their own
race that's the reality
um we can point this out all we want and
they'll ignore it
i realize that even so it must be
continually pointed out we can't tire of
meeting these false narratives because
if we do then there's no hope then
the narrative wins and that's the end of
it because the people on the left
who claim to be concerned about black
victims as we discovered are really only
concerned about a highly specific and
limited little sliver of the overall
victim category
and you know that's the case for
michelle obama but let's go to number
two
to the opposite of michelle obama here's
someone who really is concerned with
black life all black life
kim klasik congressional nominee in
baltimore
she put out an ad yesterday that that i
think is really spectacular and it gives
a blueprint
okay the point here is not just that
it's a great ad which it is but
this is other republicans need to look
at this
see it as a blueprint this is how to
deal with these sorts of issues watch
[Music]
do you care about black lives the people
that run baltimore don't
i can prove it walk with me they don't
want you to see this
[Music]
i'm kim klasic this is baltimore the
real baltimore
this is a reality for black people every
single day crumbling infrastructure
abandoned homes poverty and crime
baltimore has been run by the democrat
party for 53 years
what is the result of their decades of
leadership
baltimore is one of the top five most
dangerous cities in america
the murder rate in baltimore is 10 times
the u.s average the baltimore poverty
rate is over 20 percent
homicide drug and alcohol deaths are
skyrocketing
in our city do you believe black lives
matter
i do the vast majority of prime in
baltimore is perpetrated against black
people
who make up 60 of the population so why
don't we care about our communities
the democrat party have betrayed the
black people of baltimore
if the politicians walk the streets like
i do they would see exactly how their
policies and corruption
affects us if they don't want to see it
they don't want you to see this yeah um
as i said great ad and this is a you
know the proof is in the pudding and
this is sort of a showing the pudding
type of situation
um because the reality is as has been
pointed out many times
but you know it's it's it's fine to
point it out that can only go so far
uh sometimes you have to show instead of
tell and that's what she's doing here
these cities that have been run by
democrats for decades
are in shambles that's and
when i say shambles like literally you
look at those
you look at those images and what you're
seeing there
you know someone who's lived around
baltimore i lived in the baltimore area
myself for many years i didn't live in
the inner city
but i've been in in the city many times
i've driven through it
and i can tell you for with my own eyes
that what you saw there is not even the
worst
parts of baltimore and i assume because
in the very very worst parts
it wouldn't be smart for her to you know
walk around uh it wouldn't be safe
so that's like a few steps up from the
worst parts of baltimore that you saw
right there and it's
really really bad um to put it to put it
very mildly
and that's a a simple reality
baltimore's one example you see other
examples all across the country
chicago detroit um even new york now
is and it's getting worse there
so this is all you have to do is show it
that this is what happens with democrat
policies
now let's go um all right speak a lot of
great transitions here okay it's all
it's all
flowing very smoothly speaking of bad
democrat policies we go to andrew cuomo
uh who directly responsible for the
deaths of thousands of elderly people
intentionally exposed them to the virus
by sending infected patients into
nursing homes
that andrew cuomo just to be specific is
writing a book about
his response to the coronavirus okay uh
the
just the gumption of this guy the book
is called american crisis let me pull up
the
press release it says crown an imprint
of random house publishing
uh announced today that the it will
publish american crisis by andrew
cuomo on october 13th 2020 a revealing
behind the scenes account of his
experience leading new york through the
covet 19 epidemic
american crisis is an important
chronicle of this unprecedented moment
in history
an urgent assessment of the factors that
have and continue to impede
our national response to a devastating
health and economic catastrophe
you know a couple questions come up
right away first of all how do you have
time to write a book
right now you're currently governor this
is usually a thing you do
after you've left office after cuomo has
mercifully been voted out
which you know the people of new york
i'm not sure if they're smart enough to
actually vote him out
but because he's still relatively
popular there even though he doesn't
deserve to be
but after you leave you write the book
reflect he's writing it while he's so
he's
he's talking about how he's he's
handling the pandemic he's in the middle
of all of this
but he's got time to write a book uh and
then of course on top of all that it's
the fact that he
again is directly responsible for
killing
thousands of elderly people i wonder if
that's going to get a chapter in the
book
that's the chapter i would like to read
and that's the story
that's the story that i would like to
hear about the chapter on when he
murdered
i don't know if it'll be you know
chapter 5 when i murdered a bunch of
elderly people i don't know how he's
gonna
phrase it but that's that's that's
that's the real story from this that we
all need to
hear about um number four yesterday
president trump announced
there'd be a huge pardon of a really
important person so he made this
announcement yesterday
he said someone really important is
gonna be pardoned uh lots of people were
specula
speculating very excited who's it gonna
be uh
will it be joe exotic there was there
was that speculation on the
or you know it could have been someone
who actually deserved to be pardoned
because joe exotic does not deserve to
be
um and then today the big announcement
was made about who's getting the pardon
and here is donald trump announcing it
i wanted to just add something because
this was brought up a week ago
and i was so surprised that it was never
done before
because later today i will be signing a
full and complete pardon
for susan b anthony she was never
pardoned did you know that she was never
pardoned
what took so long
and you know that she got a pardon for a
lot of other women
and she didn't put her name on the list
so she was never
pardoned and we're uh for voting that's
right
that's right she was guilty for voting
and we are going to be signing a full
and complete pardon and i think that's
really fantastic right
that is that's great i got to tell you
uh because and it's good that he really
came through because the thing is
you wouldn't want to announce and make a
big deal out of the fact that you're
pardoning someone
uh especially when there are a lot of
people out there who really do
you know currently living and are maybe
in jail or something
and really do need the pardon so you
wouldn't want to announce that
and then do for example some really
silly pointless symbolic pardon of
someone who's already dead
you wouldn't want to do that so i'm glad
that he didn't do that in this case uh
susan b anthony
is she's been in prison for far too long
for this crime uh
and uh and so i'm glad that she'll
finally be free and she can
look return to her family and try to
reclaim some kind of life
so i i you know say congrats to mrs
anthony on that and um
you know good luck good luck of
restarting your life again and i just i
just think this is great just
uh uh really really long long overdue
all right
number five finally now now we get to
what really matters okay the only
important subject of this show to be
honest with you and certainly the most
notable event of the dnc convention last
night which is not a high bar to clear
but
there you have it uh this happened
apparently towards the end or at the
very end maybe
to wrap things up at the end of the
convention fortunately then for the dnc
most people had fallen asleep by the
time
that this happened
[Music]
there's something happening here
but it is ain't exactly clear
[Music]
everybody look what's going down
[Music]
yeah i don't i don't know
what that was or
why what why how
you know well i can figure out the how
the house but but the what and why is
really
the democrat party is seen as the party
that has people
working for it who who know how to
connect with the youth of today
and they really should have involved
some of those people in planning their
convention
because that i don't know who that's
supposed to appeal to appeal to
i suppose it appealed to the dude in the
video billy porter who's an actor or
something not really sure what he does i
know that
he wears dresses to the oscars that's
sort of his main thing that's what he
does for a living
and then he might have a couple side
gigs as well but when i see that i tell
you what when i see that
it brings to mind something i've been
thinking for a while which is that
liberals are kind of and this is going
to sound weird but
liberals are are kind of going the way
of
christian rock christian movies
christian entertainment
i don't mean that it's the same sort of
content okay what you just saw there you
probably wouldn't see that in a
christian
music video but they're making the same
mistake that christian entertainment and
the
christian entertainment industry has
made uh in that what they're doing is
they're starting to think
that a piece of entertainment is good
as long as it has the right message
the christian entertainment industry has
been doing this forever
they put out absolutely atrocious
material
but horrible production quality if it's
a movie horrible script
terrible acting a lot of really bad
music okay
but they say well it's fine it's good
because it gets the message across
and there's an audience out there for it
it's not it's not as big of an audience
as what they could get but
there's a certain audience that all they
care about is if it has a christian
message i like it
even if it's terrible quality i still
like it so um
but for a long time what made liberal
messaging
so effective in entertainment anyway is
that they actually prioritized artistic
quality and entertainment value
over the message they still had the
message they would get the message in
there more subtly
but the vehicle for it was a lot
sturdier because they were actually
paying attention to creating a sturdy
vehicle recently though it seems like
they're going the other way
um they're putting out movies songs
stuff like this that's cringy and bad
and weird and not good
but it has a message and so we're
supposed to like it so they're i think
they're making a very similar
kind of mistake which you know i guess
if you're not a liberal it's good to see
them
tripping up in this way um good to have
some company it's good that
conservatives aren't the only ones
making this mistake finally
uh let's go in fact actually i was gonna
go to the daily cancellation but before
we do there's one other thing a bonus
story we'll go to number six here
um i just wanted to play this for you
because i just saw it right before we
we started shooting here uh alexandria
ocasio-cortez
is planning uh some sort of movement to
uh help the post office because for some
reason we have to prop up the post
i don't know why you know no no one is
is out there trying to figure out a way
to keep uh
you know companies that sell record
players afloat okay
no one's worried radio shack went under
because all they did was sell
walkmans and boom boxes uh nobody was
worried about keeping them up but for
some reason we got to make
sure that we keep the post office the
reason why
the post office is suffering is that a
lot of people aren't using it anymore
because we have more efficient and
effective ways of communicating
but now all of a sudden the the left has
decided that we got to keep them going
and this is
alexandria casa cortez's idea for
keeping the post office alive
listen i have been thinking about
ways to help you help
the post office and i think i've got
an idea and i'm interested in hearing
your thoughts
so one of the best ways to support the
post office
is to buy stamps what do you all think
would you guys be down and excited
if i set up a national progressive pen
pal program
um do all the work of
connecting you to somebody else we would
offer
maybe some conversation prompts or
postcard prompts and even like a
printable postcard format
you just send it out uh would you guys
be down do you like that idea
a national progressive pen pal
program speak this is what i'm talking
about speaking of not being able
to connect with the youth alex this is
her supposed to be her thing
aoc this is what she's supposed to do
and this is what she comes up with a
national progressive
pen pal program it's like an idea that
like my aunt would come up with right
it's it's like it's like
your grandmother let's have a pen pal
program
uh but i'm i'm actually really annoyed
at uh amanda presta giacomo the daily
wire another writer at the daily wire
because she she had an angle on this
that i wish i had thought of and it
really annoys me
but she tweeted is this good for the
environment which which is a really
really good basic point here but you how
does this help
how does the post office help the
environment where you could
okay you want to send a letter to
someone you could just email it you know
and get it there at the speed of light
but instead we want to have a you know a
car a vehicle
with fossil fuels driving it to the post
i mean you put it on a plane depending
on where you're mailing it to
think of all the fuel and all the co2
and how many polar bears we're killing
and but that's that's okay i mean we got
11 years we're gonna we're all gonna be
dead in 11 years
and aoc wants to speed up the process so
that we can be pen
pals really all right
um great great idea there let's go to
our daily cancellation
before we do i want to tell you about
our most exclusive membership tier over
at the daily wire all access all access
members get to join all access live
our exclusive live stream discussions
hosted every night by each of the hosts
including my
myself um this thursday august 20th
we'll be doing a very special live
stream
uh like a watch party a live stream
for the democrat national convention's
biggest speakers hosted by
none other than i matt walsh i've been
i've been spending all day talking about
how boring and stupid the dnc is and how
relevant it is um
but i'm going to be hosting the watch
party because i'm the guy you want
just so i could tell you the entire time
how utterly pointless it is what we're
doing but that's that's really my thing
i guess you know
um the stream starts at 8 45 so don't
miss the big opportunity to tune in
and mock i mean watch the final night of
the dnc with me so i'm going to be
watching this whole thing is that the
idea
oh my god anyway it's going to be a lot
of fun
so head over to dailywire.com walsh
right now to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that's dailywire.com
walsh what did i agree to this i don't
know why i agreed they asked me they did
ask me i'll be fair they did say did you
want to do and i said
yeah i don't know why i don't know what
i was thinking
dailywire.com walsh with coupon code
walsh to get 20
off your membership how long is it is it
like two hours
two or three hours
okay let's go to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation i'm
going to be performing
another exciting fan favorite the
reverse cancellation now this is usually
the move where people are trying to
cancel me but in one graceful yet
devastating maneuver i spin around and
cancel them instead
today's cancellation will be like that
except it's an even rarer
double reverse cancellation by proxy
what that means in this case
i will be reverse canceling not people
who tried to cancel me
but who tried to cancel someone else
namely rush limbaugh
uh the canceled mob came for rush
limbaugh yesterday as they have
countless times of course over the past
30 years or whatever
whatever it is what they were angry
about this time
is that rush limbaugh called kamela
harris
a quote ho and said she was a quote
mattress
for the man she had an affair with years
ago in order to jump start her political
career now
the really interesting point about rush
saying these things is that
he didn't say these things at all in
fact the left claimed that he did but
once again it was fake news rush
merely read some news stories about how
other people had said this stuff and
were facing backlash
uh he didn't even say that he agreed
with it he just read it so
that could be the end of this
cancellation they made up a fake story
about rush
slandered him lied repeatedly etc and so
forth just another monday for our
friends
on the left but this cancellation goes
deeper than that um
let us for a moment leave aside the fact
that rush didn't actually call kamala a
ho
or accuse her of sleeping her way to the
top let us pretend
that he did say those things not because
he was reading a news report but because
those were his own opinions that he was
expressing
and in fact when i first heard about
this controversy i was duped myself
i fell for it i thought he did say it
but i was so busy not
caring about the outrage that i never
checked to see if the outrage was based
on anything that had you know
actually happened um and it turns out it
isn't but as i said let's pretend that
it is
or in fact we could just work we can go
with the reworked narrative from the
media once it was revealed that the
first narrative was bunk
that kind of reworked it and now the
headlines like here in the daily beast
it says that russia
russia perhaps didn't call kamala a ho
or say those things about her but he did
quote amplify
quote misogynistic smears he amplified
them
okay well whatever the case
what a strange dichotomy leftists are
claiming to be horribly outraged and
horribly offended by the accusation that
a woman slept around used sex to get
ahead
was quote a hoe yet it was less than a
week ago that many of these very same
people were celebrating the empowering
feminist anthem from cardi b
that expressly encourages women to do
and be
all of those things the song begins and
ends with a man shouting the word [ __ ]
and we're meant to see the word in a
positive light in the context of the
song
the women in the song are taking
ownership of it they proudly wear the
label so
what's the problem even if rush did say
it
i thought it was empowering i thought it
was a compliment
sure he wouldn't have said it as a
compliment but who cares if
you see it as a as a as positive if you
see a certain trait as positive and
someone points it out in a negative way
why would you be offended
i personally like being tall so if
someone who doesn't like tall people
came up to me and said you're tall
i wouldn't be offended or upset in the
slightest you know i i
i'm i know how i feel about who i am i'm
happy for you to notice i would say
thank you
the left here wants to reserve the right
to be offended by so-called sexist
smears even while taking ownership of
those smears and claiming that they're
not smears at all
because they're good so they say you
know x y z
is good and then a man comes along and
says you're an x y z the left recoils
how dare you
this just doesn't work it doesn't make
sense this is the trick the left tries
to pull
all the time though they want at once to
reserve the right to tell certain people
that they can't say a certain word or
make a certain accusation while at the
same time
encouraging the targeted group to live
out the word to
be it to embody it to say it to proclaim
it they do this with men too by the way
they tell men
to reject their masculinity but if you
were to go up to a man and call him
emasculated and effeminate
they would accuse you of a horrendous
slur how so i thought you said it's good
for men to be effeminate
as for women what's worse i ask to call
a woman a [ __ ] as an insult
or to try to convince young women to
actually be that
the first is rude the second is
downright sinister
and certainly far far far more harmful
to society and especially to women
so this really goes back to the old
maxim about how
you can't expect people to respect you
if you don't respect yourself
the feminist approach for years has been
to demand respect
for women from everyone except women
themselves
they want everyone else to respect and
recognize a woman's femininity and
dignity
even while working outright to relegate
feminine dignity to the societal ash
heap
but again you can't do this it doesn't
work
either being a quote [ __ ] is bad or
it's not
i say it's bad either women's bodies
should be respected or they shouldn't
i say they should either women should
not be objectified or they should i say
they should not
the left and feminists and pop stars all
want to answer those questions
conditionally intentively tentatively
and change the answer depending on who
is asking
but that's just another way of being a
hypocrite and for that
they are cancelled cancelled
cancelled all right and
we will leave it there for today thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20. aoc wants you to cut
down more trees
joe biden raps with cardi b and a major
new development
in the obama gate scandal we'll get to
all of it i'm michael knowles
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]